Okay, welcome to another memory zoom call where we're going to go over your questions that you submitted and any that you think during the zoom.
Anybody's online with us.
Chat in those questions that you might have.
And let's get to your questions.
Just a reminder everybody to look at our blog posts.
We'll never site in our website.
We have well over a thousand blog posts and it's going to find something maybe be defined something out about on Thursday afternoon can wait till next Wednesday zoom call.
You search it in that little thing about there.
First question.
Is there anything you can recommend to increase energy?
Okay, good question. Anything you could recommend increase energy.
Fair question.
But I would not be a good doctor if I didn't ask a question of a question, right?
And the question to this question would be asking the question line.
So why does a person you're going to find out why a person has a low energy?
So yeah, do you want to increase energy? What does the world tell you to do? Well, you take that energy drink.
Girl, you drink some caffeine or something like that. Well, that's not treating the real cause of the decrease energy.
So you've got to look at, okay, what's causing my decrease energy? So what could be causing decrease energy?
Or anyone, you know, whether you're a cancer patient or not.
Well, the first thing that you think of is an anemia.
So an anemia is when you have low red blood cell code or low people go with both.
If that's the case, that's definitely going to decrease your oxygen carrying capacity of your red blood cells.
That's going to decrease the energy that you're getting to the brain.
That's where you're really going to feel the decrease energy.
So a person says, I don't have any energy. They're not getting good oxygen carry capacity to the brain.
So treating the anemia. So treating the cause of the decreasing energy.
In this case, anemia is the most important thing.
So if the person has anemia with cancer, do look at our blog post about treating anemia with cancer.
But definitely, you're going to look at about adding some iron.
And if you're going to add some iron, think about adding some art emissited as well.
If your pad hired, you should always add art emissited and take them together.
Because the problem with anemia with cancer is that cancer can gobble up iron.
And if you're going to, if it's going to gobble up iron, well, that's let art emissited right with it.
So art emissited binds to iron to have information on the blog post about that.
Art emissited binds to iron and art emissited can be a cancer killer.
So we're giving the option, you know, if the cancer is going to gobble up the iron,
it's going to gobble up the art emissited into and we could actually kill the cancer via the art emissited.
So treating the anemia, treating the cause.
Let's say I have anemia due to something else.
Let's have anemia due to an infection or let's have lack of energy due to an infection or a chronic infection.
That's not an uncommon thing, a chronic infection.
How would you know that?
That would you know if your white blood cell coat is about seven, maybe seven point five tip.
That's in the normal range.
If you look at a white blood cell test, you look at a CBC test.
Typically, both labs are going to say normal white blood cell coat is 4.5 to 10.5 or maybe even 11.
But really, if you have a white blood cell coat over 7.5, you do have a hidden infection.
That could be a cause of that of the decreased energy.
You could have just inflammation.
So chronic inflammation can be a cause of decreased energy.
So that could be due to food sensitivities, food allergies.
I met people with hidden food allergies of gluten.
And you know it causes inflammation in the brain and that causes just a decrease energy.
And they get really super sleepy and can't figure out why I need to be take the drinking coffee in the afternoon.
I feel like I need to take an app.
What's probably be it's because they're eating a food that they have sensitivities to.
How would you find that out?
Run a Syrex panel.
Typically a Syrex array.
A rate 10 gives you a test of 200 or 100 different foods cooked in raw.
That would give you a good broad panel of do I have food sensitivities that I need to look at.
Remember, you know, your cheeks want testing is not going to test for antibodies to food.
So you, you know, you might have.
You know, I might have taken you off of let's say dairy or pork or something like that.
That doesn't mean you have a food sensitivity to those things.
It means that's driving your cancer.
You could have food sensitivities that is i.e.
Antibodies two different foods or peptides and different foods that can cause you all sorts of comorbidities.
So you might have cancer and you might have a decrease energy totally caused from the cancer.
But you could have cancer and you could have a covalentium decreased energy.
And it's caused from a totally different condition.
You know, that isn't even tied to the cancer.
Usually if you have anemia with cancer, that's tied to the cancer.
But you could have a chronic infection that's not tied to cancer.
You could have inflammation due to food sensitivities or food antibodies that's not tied to the cancer.
You could have another totally different disorder.
And most commonly would be an autoimmune disorder.
So looking at that might be a thing.
So looking if you have an autoimmune condition.
That would be, and that would be, you know, it should be a contact call with baby because we need to talk about that.
How you test for that is you would do a Syrix array five.
If you thought it was an auto antibodies to peripheral tissues or a seven X.
If you thought it was antibodies to neural tissue.
Syrix labs is the best labs to look for antibodies.
So no, there is it is, you know, let's say it's none of these.
And let's say, you know, a common cause for a decrease just a mile decrease energy can be an adrenal fatigue.
You know, you're getting just, you know,
just fatigue from all the weirdness of treating your computer, treating your cancer and treating your, you know, whatever.
You just have the adrenal fatigue and some low energy from just a hormone suppression.
It's common with people that are dealing with chronic disease of all kinds.
And then you'd think of what would you do for that?
You'd think of adaptogens.
So adaptogens are different nutrients that can just help bring up the Adredals, can calm down a hyperadredal state.
You can just kind of balance your hormones and can really help you with anxiety and with stress issues.
Chronic stress can certainly cause adrenal fatigue and then you end up with a decrease energy.
So that the obviously this is super fun with anybody dealing with cancer or any other, you know, disease long term.
And this can be addressed with just adaptogens.
The key of adaptogenic herbs is that you can't take too many of them, you know, you just can't and it just helps bring balance.
So if your Adredals are are fatigued, it can help bring that up.
And if your Adredals are in overdrive, cause you're just in a stress state, it can help bring that down.
Hence, adapting, adapting you to the environment, that's where it can stay.
There's some things that you think of.
What do you recommend to come at night sweats?
Some evenings I have to change my shirt anywhere from one to three times.
Thank you.
So again, you're looking for the cause.
What is the cause, right?
So you don't, you know, we are, that's all we're looking for.
What's the cause of the symptom?
Okay, well, this person knows what the cause is.
The person who asked this has a lymphoma, which causes night sweats, not all cancers do that.
There isn't anything.
If person knows the cause, lymphoma, there really isn't anything to come at the night sweats.
Adaptogens can work because part of the thought, because understand night sweats with lymphoma, it isn't fully understood why that takes place.
Because you don't get night sweats with a lot of other cancers, you don't get night sweats.
So, but it's common with lymphoma.
It's thought that it's causing an estrogen, progesterone, androgen fluctuation.
It's the one theory.
If that is true, then adaptogens could be a help.
I've had people, you do with lymphoma, take adaptogens, it was, you know, nobody has said, oh my gosh, it's just made a hundred percent difference.
Nobody said that, but nobody said nothing makes a hundred percent difference with night sweats.
I've had people say that they've had some change, they thought that it was better with that.
They're using some adaptogenic herbs.
What are adaptogenic herbs to get more specific?
We have a product called corticlear.
That would be the best adaptogenic herb for night sweats, because it helps decrease cortisol.
But we also have, we have about 10 adaptogenic products.
Apogenic herbs are corticamps, a holy basil, a luthro.
There's just a whole bunch of different herbs that fit into that category.
And there's a bunch of different blends out there that because of that.
So, different blends work for different people.
So, but I would think for night sweats, if I was going to use an adaptogens, I would try corticlear and I would take a couple in our half on the forehead.
I had the genetic testing done.
How can I find out if I was tested for the following genes, MTHFR, C-H-C-Y, C-L-M-T, M-T-T-R, M-T-R.
I don't know how to read the book I was given.
Everybody, if you've had a genetic testing done through us, you were tested for these.
MTHFR is in the folate pathway.
H-C-Y, C-L-M-T, are in the myopterin pathway, M-T-R, R, and M-T-R. That's how you make B12.
These are in the methionine pathway.
So, these were tested for and they're in your chart.
So, understand though, there's common misconceptions out there.
So, if you're googling these things or you're seeing Instagram posts about it, there's one nutritionist, quote unquote.
I don't even know who he is, but he, I just saw an Instagram video that basically said, you know, these, if you have an MTHFR defect, I can't even remember it because I scrolled past it quick.
This is a stupidest thing in the world because he gave some threat to the thing that if you have an MTHFR defect, you know, this is the most common day in America that's missed.
And this is what's causing cancer or something like that.
It's just a bunch of holy balooly.
So, MTHFR defect is methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase gene.
And you have two genes in that family.
And, you know, that was one of the more research genes and one that was originally one of the first ones that were tested in genetic testing.
And there's been a ton of misinformation about it. And I have tons of videos on this that you should watch so that you can learn about them.
And you'll learn about them in the read your genes course, which all of you listening to this have access to your remember you have full access to the read your genes course, click on it.
Start watching some of those videos that are in there that will tell you all about these genes.
And I have different videos on each one of these genes.
So, the reason why I bring this one up is because there's more misinformation about that flying around the internet than probably anything on the planet.
And a lot of well-meaning misunderstood practitioners will give somebody, you know, you have to get a methyl groups methyl tetrahydrofolate, which is the correct form of folate that person should be taking.
But because you have a gene defect on the one of these two genes in this family, everybody needs to be on that chronic and that is just totally wrong.
That impact can be very harmful, especially if you have defects on the serotonin genes.
And in the biopterate pathway, you could actually push, you know, taking too many methyl groups, I have long said, can, you know, turn off genes, which can turn off tuber suppressor genes, but also taking too many methyl groups will push the biopterate pathway, which will push an excess release of serotonin if you have defects on that gene.
That could cause all sorts of emotional imbalances, the concrete has been tied to this has to do with biopterate, which has to do with your transmitter function and neurotransmitter production, but it also has been tied to breast cancer.
So if, if you have defects in these genes, we have made recommendations on what to take based upon those defects.
So rest assured we've already addressed these, the MTRR and the MTRGD are how you cycle and create a dental comolamine and hydroxyl comolamine, which is B12.
So this is B12 production right here, if you have defects in that we typically tell you that it might be going to be taking a B12 supplement and what do we recommend, methyl B12, no, we typically recommend dental comolamine or hydroxyl comolamine because excess methyl groups are not necessarily good for cancer patient.
What is your opinion of the person left this out, so I added this to the question because the person asked the question, what is your opinion of for a person who has had estrogen driven breast cancer, the purpose, taking it would be to help make muscle.
And so I added this so if I don't think the person who asked the question is on the call.
But if you, if this is not what you meant, then please ask this question again for next week, because you didn't have the product in here, I assumed that you meant because creativity is so commonly for the purpose of healthy make muscle.
So I just added it, so if this was your question, can a person with estrogen driven breast cancer take creatine, the answer is no, so a creatine supplement, creatine supplementation is very, very popular in the exercise world.
Bodybuilders will be taking it because creatine can help build muscle and it is proven to help build muscle. So people that want to build more muscle at our lifting weights typically will be taking creatine.
I wrote a blog post about this should cancer patients take creatine so you can learn about it right there.
And the answer is no, there was a study couple studies back in the 90s that said creatine can help people with cancer, but there's been several dozen studies since then.
And some more recent ones that actually say that creatine can can increase the testis and increase the growth of a metastatic cancer.
So I just say no, and it's not just for breast cancer, it's for all sorts of cancer, but one of the studies specifically listed breast cancer was created.
So the simple answer to this should cancer patients take creatine, the answer is no, is there an easy way to queue up several right programs to run them back to back say two or three half hour programs.
Yeah, there is it's called stacking programs. So there's a video in the member site on the right three sources, the video is I just took a screenshot of the videos right here stacking programs, create your private folder and do kidding programs.
Now, in the version six point four, I haven't played with this, but it's supposed to be an easier way to stack programs. So these are some of the benefits of some of the newer versions.
And Jake, I said the version seven point, always going to even have more benefits than things like this, just to make your life of right use easier.
But it's really for people that don't have a personal program like I created three so it's people that are just who bought a right, but are just writing it for, you know, different things, you know, they want to run three foot fungus programs together when they can stack those three together.
So they're not going to have to restart the machine every two hours or whatever, how long the foot fungus program is so it's not going to be as pertinent to my, you know, our members, but, you know, the improvement.
That's why I said tell everybody, even though it can be a hassle. I think the things that the true life is trying to do is our improvements.
I have struggled with part bird for years, I use prilosec for years, realized prilosec was created, it was only improved for a maximum of 30 day use.
I use prilosec for years until I learned better and asked the doctor for another solution. I have been using pepsin for several years.
Okay, so what did I say a good doctor should do? Okay, this is, I'm just being facetious, maybe, but I think a good doctor needs to ask a simple question.
Why does the patient have heartburn? Does the patient have heartburn because they have a deficiency in prilosec?
Oh, well, prilosec is not good for us. Well, let's give him pepsin. I don't think you have heartburn because you have a deficiency in pepsin.
I don't mean to be mean, but this is the wrong thing to do. This is the wrong way to treat disease because it's not treating disease.
It's covering up symptoms. I've said it for decades. It's like, okay, my car.
Pauline Geepers, the check engine light is coming on. So what I'm going to do is take a piece of black electrical tape and I'm going to put it right over that blasted light because it bothers me.
No, no, I don't see the light anymore about that fixed. I'm going to keep driving my car.
Okay, that's silly stupid, right? Then I don't mean to be mean, but this is the way we have been taught by our medical profession to treat disease.
Hasn't it? Okay, so heartburn, okay, is a side of what?
Heartburn is a side of decreased hydrochloric acid production period.
I mean, if you have heartburn, you definitely have a decreased hydrochloric acid production by the prinal cells of your stomach.
Okay, what does that lead to? By the time you already have heartburn, you probably already have had a decreased hydrochloric acid production for probably months, and you probably already have what can be a major major cause of cancer is a major major cause of cardiovascular disease.
And it is what? H. Pylori overall. So he local actor Pylori is the most prominent, most common bacterial infection worldwide.
It is the number one causes stomach cancer, causes multiple other cancers and it's top five cause of cardiovascular disease.
So it is a bad guy. So if you have had heartburn for years, you don't need to do an H. Pylori test. You know that it's present. So you need to, I have a whole bunch of this.
Okay, so look at this blog, and that will help you the most. I actually have multiple blogs on H. Pylori with some different videos on it. So that will help you.
That's a particular podcast that you could look at.
H. Pyl with your meals is the best thing to do. But some people that have had this for years, they try taking H. Pyl and it really hurts their stomach.
That's a sign that they have a really damaged stomach cells, possibly already ulceration.
You need to switch back to taking an apple cider vinegar for a period of time with your meals. Oh my gosh, that hurts too. I can't even take apple cider vinegar.
Then you need to heal the stomach with deglycerized licorice. I have a whole protocol in that blog post that will help.
Certainly, you could need to chat with me. I'm glad they talked to you through that as well.
But dealing with H. Pylori is so, so important. The main treatment nutritional product for H. Pylori is the is a burberry.
Is your is your main nutritional killer of H. Pylori garlic works really well too.
That's why I that's why that's one of the reasons why burberry is one of my absolute favorite supplements hands down and is because she don't you know cancer is super common right but heart disease is even cometer or someone.
It's more common and number one killer in America is heart disease cardiovascular disease and it is heal H. Pylori is a major player in that.
And H. Pylori is a major player in cancer so you can keep that back down the better we can do.
I'm wondering if there's a supplement that I'm taking that could be elevated by blood sugar levels. I've always been close to 100 in the mornings and now up to 128.
I looked at your protocol and I don't the person who asked this question and I don't see anything in your protocol that would be causing an elevated.
Blue close level the only thing I saw is something that you were taking that isn't from us and that was a beetroot powder.
So depending on the source of that beetroot powder that could be it but I don't even know that you're continuing to take this so that we should probably schedule a time talk over that see what else is going on.
I went to hand surgeon to check out my finger wrist paid X-rays showed nothing wrong with my bones.
He suggested a steroid injection in my wrist for decoir veins symptoms so decoir veins syndrome it's called a syndrome is when you have paid in your wrist or hands and that was named by a maybe an orthopedic surgeon back at 1800 or something like that.
And now the medical field will treat it with just a steroid injection and you said I want to talk to you for so I know so this decoir veins syndrome is just that so whenever you it's not a disease it's a syndrome what's a syndrome is a collection of symptoms that we have no idea why it's there.
Okay so again you know you're trying to ask why right now it was the right thing to do for them to take an X-ray because at least they're trying they're asking why is there is there inflammation you know showing it the attendance is there.
So I think that's the right thing to do is to take an X-ray.
And then we'll just call it the syndrome hand in wrist paid and then we look up in Merck manual computer Merck manual no and it says to give a steroid injection.
That's you know you stopped asking why so you sometimes when something comes up you look at the person's history and you say could anything that has changed since these symptoms started to appear be responsible for it.
And we talked about this already we talked to Dr. Jan about this and she said the aromatase inhibitors can cause this and that is true and then I told you that it's most likely because of the oral chemo drugs and I would still suggest because you've been off the aromatase inhibitors and the pain hasn't blown away that it's more likely to do be due to the oral chemo drugs.
Because chemo drugs can cause what is called hand-in-foot syndrome which is exactly what you have so and again that's a syndrome we need the person just has pain and it's the chemo drugs that have have irritated the joint capsules and it can cause a secondary inflammatory arthritis that is not necessarily present.
This is visibly an x-ray or CT skin or MRI. So understand stick a step back a little bit when you have inflammation in a joint pain in a joint you ask that question why do I have arthritis now arthritis is is arthritis arthritis inflammation so you have inflammation of the joint but it is a disease.
So there's two different types of arthritic disease so there's two different types of arthritis what is in degenerative arthritis meaning that I hurt my knee in college playing football and it's you know progressively I've been able to limit it but it's progressively getting worse and now I take an x-ray and my doctor said boy you have a really a decrease joint capsule joint space
in the right knee compared to the left knee you have some degenerative arthritis taking place.
The second type of arthritis is an inflammatory arthritis that's your psorianic arthritis your rheumatoid arthritis your your achalocyne spondylitis type diseases those are inflammatory diseases which are often autoimmune.
So you have antibodies that have been developed against the joint capsule and that's causing inflammation and that's what's causing the pain now inflammatory arthritis that are autoimmune like this will can eventually lead to find needs on x-ray that's at a as the disease progresses.
Now what can cause these well heavy metals that irritate the joint capsule that cause your immune system to cause big antibodies to the joint capsule can cause that.
Chemicals, poisons like chemotherapy drugs that settle in the joint capsules remember because in the periphery the hands in the feet you have less you know blood circulation and therefore less apt to detoxify poisons that are circulating through your body and they're going to be more apt to settle in peripheral nerves causing nerve damage and nerve issues or in the joint capsule.
In the joint capsules causing inflammatory response and symptoms that are have been termed hand in foot disease due to chemotherapy so post chemotherapy patients can get them and it has to do with the with the chemical centrally in the joint capsule causing inflammatory state long term can cause an inflammatory arthritis and therefore seen on x-ray maybe one to two years later.
As the disease progresses so how do you treat that you treat it by detoxifying the chemo drugs this best you possibly can well you're this person who asked the question is already on a full bunch of key layers and binders and all this kind of stuff you can you take more of that you need to just try to you know get that out of the tissue you don't try to use the sawdust you don't use hot water baths in your hands try to get.
circulation it's all in your hands so your feet you do it in both spots try to get more circulation try to get that pumping through there as best you can can there be okay my pain is so bad can I use a drug can I use a steroid well yeah you can a steroid will decrease the inflammation can break that inflammatory cycle a little bit there can be benefits and not against using drugs if you're understanding what.
cause of this is in your treat try to treat the cause at the same time so using a medication to try to break that cycle no sense just suffering you know god has given us medication to help us prevent.
it's silly to you know you're not a greatest or something course you can use medication to do that is it bad though that's the question is it dangerous as a cancer patient to use a steroid stop right there is it bad for a cancer patient to use a steroid it depends so if so it's very common
in a person with brain cancer to be put on a steroid because the inflammation of the brain can be very dangerous because you only have so much space for that cancer to or inflammation to expand and then you could damage neural tissue so it's important to be out of steroid if you have a brain tumor.
but if you have pain let's say you're pain in your spine because of spinal tassysis and you're going on an oral steroid that can decrease the pain if that's the only thing you can do but the negatives of an oral steroid is that you are going to have some immune suppression that's the negatives of an oral steroid.
do steroid injections cause the same thing so I think this person is asking the question because she's smart enough to know that oral steroids do decrease the immune response and not a good thing to be on long term especially high dose low dose not quite so much but an oral this is not an oral steroid a steroid injection so a steroid injection is going to be a higher dose right to that area.
and of course you're going to absorb it through the rest of the tissue and it's going to circulate through the bloodstream so you're going to have some systemic effects of it but it should dissipate pretty quickly since you're only getting one injection and you're not you know taking it on a daily basis so I wouldn't be opposed to it if you know if your pain is at a point where gosh I got to do something about this is extremely crazy but opposed to doing that.
but if but also I would exhaust other things too there's different creams that a person could try come free cream.
some collendula cream might be helpful some article creams taking article might be helpful I would try to exhaust those before I did that but if my pain was like driving me crazy.
I said I don't think this is going to be a hindrance to the cancer by doing a steroid injection typically earlier than one maximum to any point.
get this the surgeon said it's not it's not certain the drugs had anything to do with it but it's too much of a coincidence for me yeah you kind of got to you know you're thinking for yourself and it's like let's all started when you know it's a time.
and it's known it's a you know the drugs that they give you are known to cause this so for them to say that a little silly but it's too much and he said that people with diabetes and hypothyroid are prone more prone to this.
I would say I'd give person if person does have you know uncontrolled diabetes yeah they can be prone to inflammatory issues in their body hypothyroid are you prone to symptoms like this apps you know that is that's that's that's not true.
and just because your TSH has been higher than usual as here doesn't mean that you're in a hypothyroid state you need to look at all those levels.
Remember that we have a new video site we're still organizing it so please be.
understanding of that but I think we have most of our videos up on that site now and the reason why we had to create that site within working diligently to get that done is because YouTube is starting to just take down our videos and it's just the right on the wall is that they will take down our YouTube site because they.
don't like any alternative practitioners that are talking about cancer.
Okay question from the chat my right bulb hasn't been lighted up the last three nights the nightly program runs as door oh but no light no sound from the bomb you know what's happening.
That's not good so if you're light if you're right light isn't lighted up at night then it's you're not getting the frequencies so.
Did the cord get pinch somehow did it get pulled out somehow is it that plugged in all the way do you have it switched to bomb make sure it's not accidentally switched to that those are the things you want to look at.
You know the bulbs typically don't burn out but they can become damaged.
And you know most common damages we've seen it just happens to get you know the solder got broken on it.
That will have to go back to true right to be replaced I can't fix a bold problem and he might just need to order a new one from true right.
It's not self fixable that way so you can't reset if you broke the solder you can't resolder it has to be a special type of solder and such so.
If you're not getting the frequencies if your bulb is not lighted up going on.
I'm going to tell my colleagues to go that I decided against keynote informal therapy he told me last time he still help me whatever I decided well that's nice.
What kind of thing should I ask that he might help me with going forward blood labs with kind of scans should I ask for how often.
Well if you're not going to do the treatment from the oncologist and they're still willing to monitor you that's the best number one reason why you stay with the practitioners if they're still willing to run labs and to cover it under your insurance.
So if they're going to charge you for labs then you want to do you do want to compare with our lab store prices because you're probably finding us are a lot less expensive but if they're going to run those through your insurance then by all means get them done through.
What lab should you run well if you've had tumors markers done and they've been elevated that I would continue to get those on a regular basis definitely get a CBC and complete metamonic panel done on a regular basis.
How much is a regular basis well if your labs are relatively normal and you're relatively stable that I would say monthly to begin with then you're tired of from tighter down from there to maybe every two months to every three months doing real well certainly you if something happens you have an increase in symptoms or something you know you try to get another set of labs to see if you can get diagnosis from that.
And those are probably the only labs that are going to be on this is a CBC complete metamonic panel and maybe two or one for instance that's the kind of run anything else you can ask them.
Scan should I ask for it how often well that's everybody's different from that you know most of our members don't want to run CT scans of PET scans and MRIs because they bring in here and you know issues with them you know CT scans and PET scans only lasted a lot of radiation unless you know it's going to make a change your decision and how you're going to trade it.
You know then I would necessarily run those even MRIs you have you know a high make that it's field that somewhat argues that the best for you and most likely use it get ready and die so really depends on you.
Some people are like don't I really need to find out I really need to know I want to get my in a CT scan and you know if you recommend the PET scan every you know X amount of months well that's your choice that that can settle your heart and settle your anxiety and then you have to make that choice whether that's right for you or not which is to know that it does.
And so I'm carrying the care at risk who is suggested that I need MRIs after my implants so if they need it to do so if they're doing a procedure and they want to make sure it was done correctly there's not any issues or negative than by all means I would agree to that to just to settle curiosity whether I'm getting better not if you've already thought again said it you know.
100 times that you only do an invasive test if it's going to change the way you treat the patient.
I use teach doctors that but teaching patients you only agree to an invasive test if you may agree to a change in your treatment schedule.
So if I've decided I'm not done with doing chemo the better if my cancer comes back with the benefits I'm not going to do it anymore within why do any tests like that so test for rupture in the implants absolutely yeah so yeah so there's reasons to do things right so.
You just got to weigh that all out and use wisdom which is a collection of knowledge from any different people as possible and you pray about it and make a decision so that's what we're all called to do you know so good good questions any other questions all right with that we'll call it a night thank you for listening we're.
look remember to look for changes on with the members only site we actually are going to have some changes in our fee schedule for follow up exams that we're actually lowering that and we're changing how to schedule that so.
just keep it around that will change so that's great all right no that I love you all I prayed for you all a daily basis and I want you to just continue to pray for us too you guys have a great night bye.